there's a viral video going around it's
really sweet it shows two little boys
meeting their adopted brother for the
first time this thing is getting a lot
of clicks people are talking about it
it's very exciting it's really sweet
again two little boys meaning their
adopted brother for the very first time
take a look those things just melt your
heart you know there's so many well it
turns out that there was another very
similar video that debuted online
yesterday and I thought this one would
go viral no one is talking about this
one right and you know the video not
going viral at all and I was confused
because it's very similar I have no idea
why this one didn't get any traction
take a look at this one
[Applause]
is take a look so deets like we drew
Andrew Michael's get back here face with
your new baby brother
I thought that was heartwarming kids can
be so difficult yeah
you